[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt einen überblick video das ist
für mich voll der zungenbrecher aber
sehr viele von euch haben schon nach
diesem video gefragt workplace ist die
glanz klausur also die spiegel klausur
die man auch im internet noch ganz
häufig sieht und die zubereitung ist ein
bisschen speziell man braucht um ein
perfektes ergebnis zu machen wirklich
spezielle zutaten wie germanische lawine
für die festigkeit dann etwas glukose
weiße schokolade und kondensmilch
so habe ich jetzt die rezeptur mal
ausgetüftelt und dies wirklich super was
aber noch wichtiger ist ist der
untergrund das heißt die torten die
dafür verwendet werden müssen zum einen
super gut schmecken und die müssen
gefroren sein das heißt ihr könnt die
super gut vorbereiten im tiefkühler
aufbewahren und dann am tag des
sanierens einfach raus holen
mit der glanz klausur über zehn und dann
servieren in diesem video zeige ich euch
jetzt die glasur also das rezept dafür
und im nächsten video kommen dann ein
paar basics wie ihr diese torten richtig
lecker zubereiten und führen können ich
muss auch ehrlich sagen dass ich mich
bisher wirklich dagegen gewehrt habe
weil es einfach so spezielle zutaten
sind aber auf euren wunsch hin machen
wir heute workplace ich zeige euch mal
die zutaten fürs mehrere claims verwende
ich zwölf gramm gemahlene gelatine 80
gramm wasser 180 gramm glukose 180 gramm
zucker 105 gramm wasser 120 gramm
gezuckerte kondensmilch und 180 gramm
weiße schokolade zuerst dem dsd gelatine
ich nehme seine rinder gelatine und da
kommt jetzt das wasser dazu - wenn nicht
zuerst ein paar quellen
das heißt kurz verrühren und dann stehen
lassen
das dauert dann etwa fünf bis zehn
minuten bis das wasser so ein bisschen
aufgezogen wird
in der zwischenzeit kann ich aber schon
mal hier im topf weitermachen und zwar
kommt jetzt die glukose hier ein
ziemlich klebrige angelegenheit da kommt
jetzt der zucker dazu und das wasser und
die mischung lasse ich jetzt aufkochen
und an zwei minuten sprudelnd kochen
ich war am ende gleich noch ein
thermometer zur kontrolle dass es etwa
105 grad celsius hat aber wir können
doch einfach zwei minuten
lassen dass die perfekte temperatur
[Musik]
nach zwei minuten kochzeit kommt jetzt
hier die kondensmilch dazu und hier habe
ich jetzt die gezuckerte kondensmilch
aus der dose
diese auch recht lange haltbar das heißt
ihr könnt ihr dann im kühlschrank
weiterhin aufbewahren oder den carrera
mit süßen und jetzt die schokolade mit
rein und so lange rühren geschmolzen ist
[Musik]
nächstens auch die gelatine soweit man
sieht es hier ganz gut und die kommt
jetzt hier auch mit rein und dann kann
ich alles verrühren und die glasur dann
abkühlen lassen auf etwa 35 grad so dass
er wirklich handwärmer hat denn so ist
jetzt einfach noch ein bisschen zu heiß
ich habe jetzt schon meine torten seit
gestern und vorgestern im gefrierfach
das heißt dies im richtig gut
durchgefroren und dafür verwende ich am
liebsten silikon formen weil an die
oberfläche schön glatt wird und
natürlich auch beim gegner so schön
bleibt unterlaufen kann
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt das merklich abkühlen
lassen und so sieht ja die ursprungsform
aus das ist auch noch ein bisschen warm
ich habe nämlich noch mal eine portion
gemacht und so sieht sie aus wenn man
ein bisschen eissing weiter nach rein
macht also ein bisschen weiße
lebensmittelfarbe als in pulverform
dann hat man nämlich eine schöne helle
farbe kann auch noch ein bisschen rein
machen das ist wirklich ganz weiß wird
und das kann ich jetzt ein werben mit
verschiedenen lebensmittel verpassen
ich habe hier schon meine torte die habe
ich gefühlt mit einer weißen
schokoladenmousse im inneren habe ich
einen frucht kern darunter einen richtig
leckeren schoko boden und einen krampf
boden
die torte ist wie gesagt gefroren und
aus der silikonform kommen sie wirklich
perfekte rundheraus er könnte super
vorbereiten im gefrierfach lagern
zusammen einfach nur nach dekorieren
ich habe jetzt mal kurz die masse ein
und dann kümmerte kurieren
[Musik]
und hier beim verrühren einfach darauf
achten dass ihr nicht so viel luft ein
schlag damit einfach keine büro bläschen
entstehen und falls doch kann man es
auch der von hasen streicheln das ist
dann auch hier sind marmoriert lass ich
das hier jetzt nämlich meine grundfarbe
die kommt jetzt hier in ein gefäß also
viel brauche ich nicht wichtig ist dass
man wirklich reichlich mehr workplace
hat dann kann es auch danach wirklich
und wieder runter kratzen und dann neu
erwärmt und wiederverwenden jetzt die
verschiedenen phasen noch rein und so
könnt ihr ein richtig tolles muster
herstellen
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr zum beispiel mit
einem teig scharrer oder löffel wir
einen fehler machen und dann die klasse
über die gefrorene torte gießen
[Musik]
wo sie einfach nur aufpassen dass
überall die glasur ist und da kommen
noch 2 3 hinten drauf weil die
luftbläschen habt könnt ihr jetzt
einfach ein bisschen klopfen oder die
luft bläst mit einer nadel auf stechen
[Musik]
nachdem abtropfen einfach unten die
letzten reste wegnehmen und dann auf
eine tortenplatte setzen auftauen lassen
unser werden
[Musik]
ihr euch jetzt blau und weiß gemischt
und kleinen wirbel gemacht jetzt über
diese form und wenn man jetzt so zur
mitte hin gehst dann bekommt man schöne
streifen
[Musik]
jetzt habt ihr ein paar inspirationen
gesehen die reste von mary chase die
habe ich jetzt verpackt die kann ich
nämlich jetzt im kühlschrank aufbewahren
und dann zum beispiel in der mikrowelle
oder auf dem herd warmmachen
wichtig ist nur dass man das mich kochen
lässt wegen der gelatine und dann kann
man es erst wieder verwenden also super
cool jetzt lieber murat ist ganz wichtig
natürlich dass man die torten dann
auftauen lässt am besten bei
raumtemperatur einfach zwei drei stunden
stehen lassen je nach größe der torte
als er merkt ja dann auch ob sie schon
gut zu schreiben geht oder eben doch
nicht
ich bin mir sicher für das erste mal
probieren und herzen abschneiden das
herz brechen
oh mein gott das ist noch ein bisschen
kalt aber geht schon
[Musik]
die spitze nicht erwischt weil sie noch
so fest und so gefroren war
aber cool oder ja mal gespannt aber ich
will mich sagt geschmack müsste da sie
ja ja und der geschmack also ich habe
jetzt heute meine grundrezept praktisch
von der später so mit euch geteilt und
geschmacklich gibt's einfach das nächste
video denn da könnt ihr mal schauen
da habe ich dann eben die grundrezepte
und daneben auch die abhandlungen wie
ihr das ganze variieren können
partnerschaftlich hälfte aber noch ein
bisschen kalt so murat ich hab ihn
gestellt
ok ich probiere es irgendwie aus wie
wiso milka schlüssel
und man die klasse schmeckt nach weißer
schokolade und ihnen darin kann man ja
machen eben auch eine erdbeere
unternehmen
ja und ich finde es gar nicht so schwer
wichtig ist eben nur dass die torte
vorher richtig schön glatt ist daher
arbeit hier damit silikon formen die
benutze ich nicht zum backen sondern nur
zum füllen und einfrieren so bekommen
sie die schöne glatte oberfläche und
dann ist einfach nur wichtig die glasur
auf die richtige temperatur zu kriegen
richtig schöne farben schon früher
machen können weil ich bin echt lecker
ich habe auch gedacht geschmückten noch
gar nicht so kommt auch gefühle
natürlich wie immer ja eben das
enthalten was hast du den boden gelangen
das kann triumph erweitert wurde hast du
dich zu dem nächsten medien bald ihr
also das rezept nach machen möchtet dann
macht schon mal die workplace kanzler so
macht eure torten fc 1 gestaltet sie und
postet sie dann auf facebook und
instagram und markiert mich natürlich
weil wir dann hält die fragen auch schon
mit der glanz des bistums auf ist also
ob er zwei tage das hier ja auf jeden
fall also ich würde jetzt wenn ich sie
heute essen bin heute bei raumtemperatur
aufbauen
ansonsten aber noch durch einen
kühlschrank bis morgen viel spaß beim
nachmachen ich freue mich auf eure
kreationen bis dann natürlich
[Musik]